bonne année à tous soyez les bienvenus
dans le journal de l'afrique sur france
24 à la une ce soir l'inquiétude de la
société civile guinéenne alpha condé a
été autorisé par la junte au pouvoir a
quitté le pays pour se faire soigner à
l'étranger même si l'ancien président ne
doit pas s'absenter plus d'un mois de
nombreux guinéens craignent qu'il ne fût
la justice de son pays nous serons à
conakry dans un instant une grande
partie du parlement sud africain partis
en fumée à un incendie qui s'est déclaré
dimanche a violemment repris lundi après
midi les pompiers avaient pourtant
réussi à le maîtriser dans la nuit après
24 heures d'intenses combats les détails
dans ce jaune et à la fin de cette
édition nous allons évoquer la polémique
du moment au sénégal la fédération
sénégalaise de football se bat pour
pouvoir récupérer son joueur ismaïla
sarr il est retenu par watford son club
anglais et ne pourra peut-être pas
participer à la coupe d'afrique des
nations la compétition commence dans
moins d'une semaine la correspondance à
dakar dans un autre
c'était une demande de la cedeao adressé
par courrier à la junte au pouvoir en
guinée l'ancien président alpha condé va
pouvoir quitter le pays pour se faire
soigner à l'étranger à condition de ne
pas s'absenter plus d'un mois mais de
nombreux acteurs de la société civile
s'inquiète de ce voyage et crème qu'il
n'en profitent pour échapper à la
justice de son pays les détails avec
notre correspondant à conakry
malik diakité selon le communiqué c'est
un voyage à caractère purement médical
dont mois maximum sauf avis contraire de
ses médecins le document ne fait aucune
mention de la date de son départ ni de
sa destination sous pression la gente
militaire pouvons en guinée c'est aussi
à une exigence de la cedeao qui avait
demandé la libération d'alpha condé une
décision saluée par les partisans de
l'ancien président le collectif le parti
politique rpg à l'ancienne et annie
se réjouit de cette avancée
significative
intervenu dans le traitement de la
situation du professeur alpha condé
perçoit cet acte comme un facteur de
consolidation
de la paix et de la concorde sociale
dans nos vies la société civile salue
également la mesure mais elle souhaite
voir alpha condé faire face à la justice
c'est salutaire l'acte qui a été pris
par le cnrd de permettre à monsieur
alpha condé de sortir va aller se faire
soigner mais aujourd'hui nous attendons
à pied ferme que monsieur alpha condé
vient répondre devant la justice parce
que avec tout ce qui s'est passé et on
ne peut pas dire qu'il est coupable ou
pas mais je souhaitais lyon bien que la
justice se prononce là dessus si alpha
condé a pu bénéficier d'une autorisation
de sortie du pays ce n'est pas le cas
des responsables de son régime déchu ils
sont toujours interdits de voyager même
pour des raisons de santé médicale leurs
documents de voyage et restos sont
confisqués par la gente militaire au
pouvoir
un épais nuage de fumée s'est de nouveau
échappé des toits du parlement sud
africain un incendie s'est déclaré
dimanche soir les pompiers étaient
parvenus à le maîtriser après 24 heures
d'intenses combats mais le feu est
reparti lundi après-midi chez
redessineront
lundi matin ses pompiers du cap qui le
parlement soulager le feu déclaré la
veille est sous contrôle mais quelques
heures plus tard les flammes reprennent
dans le toit du bâtiment dont la
structure est en bois
c'est une mission difficile pour nos
hommes à cause de la pente du toit et le
vent qui attisent les flammes
un suspect arrêté alors qu'il n'avait
rien à faire dans le bâtiment vide est
inculpé pour vol avec effraction et
incendie criminel l' enquête commence à
peine et les autorités sont assaillis de
questions pourquoi le système anti
incendie n'a pas fonctionné est ce que
le parlement était assez sécurisé
nous tenons cette conférence de presse
pour assurer les sud africains que le
discours sur l'état de la nation sera
tenu comme prévu
le budget sera voté
les commissions parlementaires
continuerons aussi leur travail
pour le président cyril ramaphosa qui a
visité le site dimanche l' incendie est
un coup terrible pour l'afrique du sud
des oeuvres et des objets historiques
datant pour certains du xviie siècle se
trouve à l'intérieur mais surtout les
parlements sont un lieu hautement
symbolique c'est là que s'est achevée la
lutte contre l'apartheid et pour la
liberté
au soudan le général al banna de nouveau
un boulevard devant lui le premier
ministre de transition abdel hakim doc
jette l'épongé il avait menacé à
plusieurs reprises de quitter l'accord
politique qu'il avait conclu avec la
junte faute de consensus n'a bien marc
koffi
seul maître à bord le puissant général
album libre de manoeuvrer à sa guise
privé du pouvoir de transition le
premier ministre à mme daka préféré
rompre le pacte imposé par la junte dans
les rues de khartoum les réactions à
cette annonce sont mitigés
c'est une si grande perte pour le pays
le prochain ne pourra pas faire ce qu'il
a fait
parce que ce qu'il a accompli
ce n'était ni simple ni facile il a
tellement donné pour le pays
le peuple soudanais ne voulait pas que
amdocs démissionne mais le conseil
militaire l'a poussé à le faire
au jour à de ces gens là et j'espère que
leur heure viendra bien que
notre combat est plus grand plus
important que lui donc il reste ou qu'il
parte ça ne fait pas vraiment différent
on continuera sur notre chemin
révolutionnaire
et ses images auront sans doute accéléré
la décision du premier ministre des
civils au sol ciblé par des grenades
lacrymogènes ou des tirs à balles
réelles une nouvelle preuve s'il en
fallait de la répression militaire en
cours en 2019 lorsqu'il est désigné
premier ministre de transition abdallah
mme doc incarne l'espoir mais le 25
octobre dernier il est évincé et placé
en résidence surveillée
rétabli dans ses fonctions un mois plus
tard il perd la confiance de la roue et
son renoncement aujourd'hui ne fait que
précipiter le pays dans une nouvelle
période d'incertitude
cette attaque au kenya six personnes ont
été tuée dans le comté de l'amuhf une
région de l'est du pays près de la
frontière somalienne lors d'une attaque
possiblement menée par des rebelles
islamistes shebab
direction le gabon où la cour
constitutionnelle s'est de nouveau
prononcée sur des mesures
gouvernementales liées à la crise
sanitaire la juridiction a annulé
l'obligation d'un pass sanitaires pour
accéder aux lieux publics et à rejeter
pour la deuxième fois consécutive un
arrêté du gouvernement concernant de
nouvelles mesures contre le coc u19 la
correspondance à libreville 10 mais
l'audience et
la haute juridiction vient de donner
raison à une organisation de la société
civile qui l'avait saisie estimant que
les libertés publiques et individuelles
été floués en raison de l'instauration
des tests pcr payant la facture des
tests pcr est comprise entre 20 et 50
mille francs cfa soit entre 30 et 75
euros sans oublier l'obligation des
gabonais de présenter un pass anitea
pour accéder à leur lieu de travail ou
dans des espaces publics bars
restaurants entre autres c'est une
victoire dont historique inespérée pour
la société civile dans l'ic ici à
libreville au sujet n'en a pas fini
d'alimenter les débats la réaction
officielle des autorités se fait
toujours attendre le gouvernement a
toujours manifesté son ambition de
vacciner plus de 60% de la population
contre 12 le taux actuel de couverture
vaccinale
il dispose désormais d'un délai d'un
mois pour revoir sa copie
je vous emmène à présent à plus de 1000
km au nord de bamako dans le delta du
fleuve niger là bas la population qui
vit de l'agriculture souffre des
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
une zone rurale où les villageois ne
sont pas non plus épargnés par la montée
en puissance des groupes armés qui
contrôlent la zone et recrutent les
jeunes le plus souvent sans emploi
reportage d'un fleurs lespiau
sur le fleuve niger au coeur de la
région de tombouctou le village de
tasses à cannes inaccessible par la
route en saison des pluies ce jour là
cette équipe de la mission de l'onu au
mali accompagné par une ong locale vient
rencontrer la population qu'elle aide en
mettant en place un projet rizicole dans
ce village de près de 1700 habitants la
riziculture est la principale source de
revenus une activité gage de sécurité
mais fragilisée chaque année par le
niveau imprévisible des précipitations
liées au réchauffement climatique
actuellement ça va parce qu'un document
avance initiale avec l'uci à palau
les gens ont même comme de ceux qui
l'aident à mamadou est l'un des
spécialistes venus aider les
cultivateurs à optimiser la culture du
riz a commercialisé ensuite par les
habitants où la levée sur ce système de
canaux d'irrigation installé sur 30
hectares de rizières ça c'est le canal
tout l'espace qui amène l'eau au niveau
du périmètre qui fait un long de 200
mètres vous voyez que les épines sont en
train de chanter donc on est presque à
la récolte un canal qui permettra d'ici
quelques soirées du temps de récolter
près de 180 tonnes de riches mais le
problème récurrent pour ces exploitants
c'est aussi le manque de matériel
agricole et la forte augmentation cette
année du prix des engrais en charge
cette société à la maison ils ont dit
les intérêts les intrants agricoles
tels que les engrais le gasoil ainsi de
suite on affirme même que quatre fois tu
travailles tués dans ces heurts a
permis à près de 160 jeunes de retrouver
un emploi pendant trois ans il ya
beaucoup de jeunes aussi qui sont
arrêtés dans les développeurs mais aussi
bon avec ces périmètres ce cas là on a
pu récupérer tous ces jeunes là dégainer
le pour qu'on cultive un simple non
vraiment c'est la soulager
as tu as à cannes comme sur l'ensemble
du territoire malien les difficultés
d'accès aux ressources liées au
dérèglement climatique provoque de
nouvelles tensions entre les peuls
on en vient à ce bras de fer entre la
fédération sénégalaise de football et le
club anglais de watford à une semaine de
la coupe d'afrique des nations la
fédération sénégalaise de football se
bat pour la libération de son joueur il
se bat et la sarre tout a commencé par
un communiqué de la fédération
sénégalaise de football publié ce
dimanche et accusant watford le club de
l'ailier sénégalais de vouloir retenir
le joueur et le privé de la can les
détails à dakar de notre correspondant a
dit mme ndao
la fédération sénégalaise de football
qui est à exprimer sa profonde
réprobation du comportement
irrespectueux discriminatoire et
pernicieux des dirigeants de votre foi
c'est là un extrait du communiqué de la
fsif public dimanche la fédération
sénégalaise de football ne comprends pas
pourquoi votre phone libertarisme et les
stars pour qu'il puisse participer à la
prochaine coupe d'afrique à des nations
ismaila ça il faut le dire est l'un des
meilleurs joueurs de l'équipe nationale
du sénégal de football l'un des joueurs
les plus décisifs c'est pourquoi le
sénégal compte beaucoup sur lui watford
n'a pas tardé à réagir aux propos de la
fsf ils ont également publié un
communiqué dans lequel est là précise
qu'ils se marrer ça est blessé depuis le
mois de novembre et qu'il est toujours
en convalescence et pourquoi il ne
l'autorisent pas à répondre à l'appel de
la sélection nationale ce conflit n'est
pas donc isolé plusieurs internationaux
africains de football sont bloqués par
leur club et ne devrait probablement pas
participer à la prochaine coupe
d'afrique des nations des clubs
européens s'estiment lésés de devoir
faire partir leurs internationaux
africains de football au moment où les
championnats européens sont toujours en
cours allez à la fédération africaine de
football de leur côté à rétorque par le
règlement de la fifa la fédération
internationale de football qui oblige
les clubs européens à laisser partir
leurs internationaux pour répondre à
leur sélection nationale a' lors des
compétitions internationales
ces images de clôture des jeux
traditionnels de niamey la capitale
nigérienne a organisé la 42e édition du
championnat national 2 traditionnel il
s'agit du sport le plus ancien et le
plus populaire au niger bien plus qu'un
simple combat la lutte est une fierté
nationale le champion a d'ailleurs reçu
un montant de 10 millions de français
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]